right so Robert wit the superball five
days away if you haven't bought a ticket
is it too later should you just wait
until the last minute you know what
here's the good news because this year
unlike most other years the ticket has
been going down in price over the last
couple of weeks what happened was
everyone was assuming the Dallas Cowboys
were gonna get into the game America's
Team
America's team right not the Patriots
but America's team because they have
such a huge following everyone thought
that if they got in the game there'd be
such demand so a lot of these brokers
set their prices really high we all know
they didn't get in the game it's the
Falcons versus the Patriots and right
now tickets are at the lowest point
market value that I've seen in at least
five years so if you wait a little bit
more you could get a better deal well
it's just like the stock market right so
it could go up because people could come
into town there could be demand but
right now if you wanted to buy a getting
ticket for the Superbowl you'd be paying
twenty five hundred dollars that sounds
like a lot but in reality for market
value that's actually a great price okay
so including this year the Patriots I
believe have gone to the Super Bowl
three times since 2012 they have a one
each one but to the extent that they're
not America's team does that affect
demand or do people and here I'm talking
about corporates turnout and pay up no
matter who's playing well corporates
definitely they'll they'll turn out and
they'll pay up no matter who's playing
they're going because it's the Super
Bowl now New England fans have
definitely been spoiled so you know we
go back to 2001 when they had that first
trip to the Super Bowl and most people
then in New England probably mortgaged
the house to buy that Super Bowl ticket
they've been back several times as we
all know so there's not that feeling of
hey I gotta go people actually sitting
on the sidelines and waiting so you know
for right now they're not okay so talk
about some of the deals the package
deals that you can still get with five
days to go what's included well here's
the great news right so the Super Bowl
ticket is really the most expensive part
of a package and as we've said the Super
Bowl ticket is at a low point but here's
what you can do so you can get a ticket
to the game hotel now Hotel is actually
funny enough one of the hardest things
to come by in Houston because there is a
limited supply
o great hotels but these packages
they'll include the ticket the hotel
transportation there's all these parties
we can include in our pack
there's all add-ons in terms of gifts so
there's really a full luxury experience
that can still be created even this late
how bespoke can the experience get could
people say I want to go to a party with
that person or I want to get into this
particular event well it's incredible
what you can really buy nowadays so for
sure so some of our packages will
include access to attend some of the big
parties like the DirecTV party with
Taylor Swift this year or Pepsi's party
with Bruno Mars the chainsmokers are
performing at a party on Thursday night
we can include all of those elements in
our packages and we also can include the
option to add off let's say with a
former NFL player we could set you up
for dinner with a former NFL player even
some of the coach's announcers there's
so many people in town so many
celebrities that we can create these
bespoke packages and really they can
include the most incredible things now
you've been in this business for the
past 20 years and obviously a lot of
these experiences are new but if you
could compare and contrast the pricing
the transparency in sourcing and pricing
of tickets since you know over the last
10 years over the last 20 years well
here's the great thing when I first
started in this business back in
nineteen maybe 99 2000 there was no
StubHub so there was no transparency
there were no secondary ticket sellers I
had to make an agreement with a ticket
broker who is going to deliver my
tickets on-site so I never knew really
in terms of was I going to get those
tickets and I had all these corporate
clients at the event nowadays what's
great is there is an actual market so
you can monitor that market just like I
advise people now saying hey the tickets
at an all-time low you can actually see
that the regular fan can see that back
in the day when I was first doing this I
was trusting some guy and meeting a guy
on the corner on the street to purchase
tickets it's a whole different world
which is great but at the same time it's
still very similar and one other thing
is that I would say 2000 was the year I
remember paying $1500 market value for a
get in Super Bowl ticket which is the
cheapest ticket this year before this
market went down we were paying 4500
dollars so that's about 15 years it's
gone up $3,000 all right as